[Music]
reading scrolling reading at that movie
wants to be lazy but expects you to work
what kind of lives were these assholes
living to be separately bitten by a
battle wolf and then become leaders of
two different races movie consulted
James Cameron before choosing its fonts
also in case you confused it with 1202
BC which we totally would have done oh
my god
discount Thor and Loki oh dear
here comes action which in the
underworld realm means I'm not gonna
understand anything due to rapid editing
murky and jerky cinematography and
characters that all pretty much look the
same werewolves blindsiding stunt guys
underworld to ancient battles you don't
care about movie waste time on a
werewolf transformation just so random
vampire guy can cut his head off I don't
think any of these people in the
background are do injection and I swear
- vampires are fighting each other
somewhere in here let's write to the
woods
I wish die and fight and all that some
things were defeated by the something
else's is this a werewolf or is this an
orc I am beginning to think it doesn't
matter honestly how does the director
himself you didn't understand it what's
going on here it's like someone telling
you a story like this and then there was
a werewolf in all these chains and I
think it was that guy's brother anyways
some things happened I can't remember
all of it but damn it was exciting he
was not to be harmed how did you expect
that to happen the motherfucker is a
werewolf
do you have tranquilizers chloroform
from you
couldn't you just have given us all that
information in the scrolling red text I
mean if you're gonna bother with
scrolling text to set the stage why do
you also need a 9 minute opening action
scene to set the stage that's like
having your cake and beating a dead
horse with it two four six centuries I
was a loyal soldier of the vampire clan
previously on underworld also someone
said you remember in the first movie how
it was hard to see a damn thing let's
chop it all up and make it more out of
focus I can find no lichen but a hybrid
did you write the script for us or to
remind yourself so far underworld
evolution is slower than actual
evolution my only hope now is to awaken
Marcus and expose the truth the full
Craven tries to murder him while he's
still in hibernation honestly we're
already and I don't give a fuck
territory what is everyone fighting for
again to hold dominion over all this
darkness lack of humor and nearly
complete lack of sex it's like having a
war over my first girlfriend movie does
not come with instructions on how to
date Kate Beckinsale in the vampire
world she's a wanted criminal but sure
they still haven't removed her
thumbprint or key code for high-security
areas
[Music]
perfect what does it matter if the
lights come on or not aren't you
creatures of the night
haven't you been spending hundreds of
years in darkness exactly like this the
hell you need a flashlight for
jump-scare makes me jump sad someone
could have picked us up already
especially since you used the thumbprint
to enter I'm going to learn you can stay
here at the safe house I just said we
couldn't stay at for very long well at
least this isn't taking forever
what is the floor made of drywall or
something shooting is hard first movies
villain total bitch
okay so Celine's that they needed to
prevent Craven from killing Marcus looks
like that job is done will be over right
someone just died so birds must scatter
cliche
Michael you unique has never been a
hybrid before yeah why is that in 800
years not one this movie came out in
2006 do you have any idea what kind of
power they'd need for all this gear not
to mention that it's all apparently
operating on a wireless system on a boat
in the ocean or what vampires have their
own satellites to boat and its swanky
Jack Bauer war room oh man they track
poor Tony and Emmy award-winning Derek
Jacobi into this didn't they yes what I
have sir is a Sony product placement
opportunity disguised as a bit of
exposition we need to go doesn't Marcus
need to drink the blood of Celine to
figure out exactly what happened in this
room
dude just walks in and suddenly he's the
guy from the dead zone okay so how does
a stupid thing work
let me consult Cravens blood and matrix
that bit into my brain because I'm sure
he has strong memories of typing in his
blood
next stop drink the blood of Mavis
Beacon so I can type even faster
thankfully for Marcus vampires somehow
have a photographic memory of the people
who they bytes lives even details those
people themselves would surely have
forgotten or not bother to remember in
the first place hey the Jeepers Creepers
see this is why you don't leave like in
vampire hybrids in a safe house you know
we'll be tracked
you learn this stuff in kindergarten
meanwhile maybe Celine could only barely
make it to the mansion by Dawn because
she was planning on walking there Marcus
took a very specific route to the safe
house that flew him directly over Celine
regular food will make you sick don't
you remember Celine saying that or do
you just not care or are you bound by a
ridiculous screenplay full of bullshit
dumbass coincidence news just happens to
be on it just happens to report on
Michael as he has werewolf spasms in the
tavern next news story food poisoning
scare at whatever this tavern is called
Oh
ah I see this impossible boat command
centers also somehow monitoring every
phone call made in the world
how have they not started shooting yet I
mean I know they'll have terrible aim
and he's probably immune to bullets but
what are they waiting for nearer helps
Michael to stay a good guy and not eat
this police officer
this mirror is like the best friend who
knows the real you is inside the monster
somewhere discount Trinity no seriously
just roll with it
he missed trust us okay take it no
Michael you'll die what the hell good is
the first ever vampire Lycan hybrid if
you can't take some bullets and keep
moving I'm starting to think Michael is
the bull mastiff of this movie's genetic
experimentation they were going for
brutal warrior but ended up with wussy
love bunny blood drinking is sexual for
vampires but not the audience cliche -
bird scatters in 30 minutes of movie
these assholes need to form a union
convenient escape truck just happens to
be moseying along a country road for
vampires to steal it
immortal boxing also Michael a brand new
wolf vampire hybrid will now hold his
own against Marcus one of the two
ancient vampires this series has told us
is basically unstoppable okay old truck
driving down a lonely road with a flying
demon creature attacking the guy and
girl inside character design isn't the
only thing this movie stole from Jeepers
Creepers flying demon immortal vampire
is so shaken up by the bump that he
slumps on the road forever and lets
these assholes get away he didn't die
inconceivable wait he's a vampire that's
actually pretty conceivable so why did
Selene and Michael act like they did
something positive why does the movie
actually let them get away the Sun not
only burns vampires but also the gloves
they wear performance art concerned non
medical exam turned sexy cliche there's
was a forbidden romance I mean the kids
would be one-quarter werewolf and
three-quarters vampire man they're gonna
have some fucked up kids my god I'm
taking three sins off here and not
explaining why to any of the idiots in
the audience this is a rated R action
film about vampires but it goes all PG
on the sexy scenes because well honestly
because the star is married to the
director in other words reasons we can't
show you the sexiest bits of the scene
because the director wanted to keep that
for himself and for diet coke
commercials yeah you better cover up
you never know who's watching when
you're in an abandoned warehouse in the
middle of the country character suddenly
recalls long dormant memories pertaining
to the plot cliche andreas Tanis Selene
waits until she gets stressed and
they're ready to go before telling
Michael who the hell she meant by
someone Cobbins hire historians he was
exiled over 300 years ago what makes you
think we're gonna find him now I was the
one who accepted exile means to ban
someone from one's own home country it
does not mean that person is banned from
going anywhere else
the second Lycan is coming to the battle
late because even werewolves attacked
one by one you know even if I have
werewolves change downstairs I am NOT
leaving an open stairway for them to
access the rest of the house you know
because of precautions issue I knew is
usually extensive Victor's blood still
lingers in your veins also I saw you on
the security monitor before you walked
in you don't scare me Selene on cue and
consistent with the movies convenience
factor Michael comes crashing through
right after Selene says this also where
did Michael come from how did he get
from the wolf dungeon to a room with no
exits and a boarded-up window we clearly
saw Selene go up some nice steps earlier
from basically the same place and when
he crashes through it looks like there's
fog from the outside coming in what the
kitty
Marcus was after this why you threw it
to him instead of just calmly showing it
to him why also why would you toss this
to a bad guy good God there are always
flocks of birds ready to be disturbed
whenever this guy goes anywhere also
what is the point of this fucking scene
he drank the horses blood poor horses
now we really know Marcus is evil this
scene serves as a post-it note to remind
us Marcus is still out there he didn't
return Victor was to use his army to do
mortal to help him to do what I don't
know Selene if you let him finish maybe
he'll tell you then country William
hooked him away why listen you for the
very same reason that Victor never
conspired against Marcus fear this
discussion will proceed to go back and
forth talking about Marcus and William
in such a manner that it's nearly
impossible to keep track of right after
Selene figures out that William was
protected because Victor thought killing
him would wipe out the Lycan slaves
Tanis says so Marcus was protected
protecting Marcus has nothing to do with
protecting William in this scenario but
the screenplay thinks it does it's
Williams prison the prison your father
was commissioned to build what why were
regular humans commissioned to build a
prison for a werewolf
why does Marcus looking for him now
after all this time that I kind of own
Stan but I do know someone guy they went
to see for answers knows nothing except
the name of the next guy they can go to
for answers what is this a transformer
sequel these vampire bite downloads tell
Marcus everything pertinent to his quest
and shows it to him in the same camera
angles as the movie itself you know the
devastation caused before he was
captured he cannot be set free I've got
a Marcus a Victor a Craven Ellucian this
Alexander Corvinus guy and a fucking
William and they speak of all these
fucking dicks with the same hushed ah to
the point where I literally have no
fucking clue what's going on Marcus who
is somewhere somewhere high somehow knew
that he could poke his extendo wing
through the window and stab something
anything and knew that Michael was
wearing the pendant also after his wing
fines purchase he says get well let
gravity decide what happens to Michael
Celine has an extremely valuable vantage
point here and could easily empty her
gun into Marcus now but decides to jump
down and be stupid instead random
asshole just happens to have died on a
deck near a spot where the helpless
Celine can pick up a gun
what an entire magazine of bullets from
the automatic weapon didn't faze this
asshole or stop him from trying to kill
Celine but now that a handgun is
involved he's incapacitated and has to
go fly off and lick his wounds
how come vampire blood is medicine but
this guy who is half-vampire needs
vampire blood medicine to live doesn't
he already have vampire blood in him the
movie may have answered this question I
will be honest but he'll if I'm going
back through this piece if she began to
find it I have no clue why Marcus
decided to go through the other part of
the ship when there are now two gaping
holes leading straight to the room
Alexander is in they can't get dependent
yes no he didn't he lost it right here
he gets shot and loses it and never
recovers it also this movie has just
become super confusing again apparently
there aren't two keys one is a pendant
that Alexander took from Victor's body
the second is a smaller pendant that we
saw Lucien wearing in the first movie
that Michael took Tanis said there were
two keys but he didn't say it needed
both corpse rubbing 10 seconds of
staring and mortal explodes in a ship
but he's immortal so the explosions can
kill immortals I'm beginning to think
that word has lost its meaning MacGuffin
item this MacGuffin underworld 2 book of
secrets I don't know about you guys but
I remember the exact directions of
everywhere I went when I was 6 years old
and much like Selene I remember after
hundreds and hundreds of years and the
original vampires were basically just
Rube Goldberg fans each way
oh fuck you you're too late well you
were too late when you left the docks
right
I mean Marcus flew off and you knew
where he was going so this should be no
surprise at all
impressive cliche why are bullets so
suddenly effective against this guy why
hasn't this guy changed into a
super-powerful Jeepers Creepers form yet
why am I still watching this movie
random bullsh rocks stopped the wall
from closing all the way because if we
made it this far we'll accept anything
we have no idea what Michaels true
strength and power is as the first
hybrid we have no idea what Celine's new
true strength and power is after sucking
old dudes blood and we never really had
a firm grasp on Marcus and Williams true
strength and power either so this is all
meaningless these could have been used
earlier like always especially since you
knew bullets weren't going to kill him
anyway damn how many dudes did they
bring on this tiny helicopter spinning
propellers serve to remind us that
someone's going to get chopped up
Raiders of the Lost Ark style ah so
that's what the old man's blood did it
turned her into blade awesome how will
we get back home if I know we're
surrounded by water and mountains damn
we're going to have to do a lot of
fucking to figure this one out
[Music]
and that was the end of the underworld
series an unknown chapter lies ahead
dammit all that is certain is that
darkness is still ahead but for now for
the first time I look into the light
with a new heaven nothing is certain
darkness is all I see this makes me
hopeful it sounds like the screenwriter
just wanted to end this thing on a
positive note even if it didn't make
sense from you huge thanks to our pal
Matthew Santoro forgets narrating on
this sins video please check out his
channel where he makes awesome list
videos was including today's video where
he talks about the 10 most cursed movies
of all time and to Matt thank you very
much buddy
[Music]
look nobody's saying they don't
appreciate we're not done right no in an
order at Pepsi here's a 50 then wait for
a guy named Griff right right
tips gonna ask you about tonight are you
in or out
tell him you are out whatever he says
whatever happens say no you're not
interested
one two three four five six seven
Oswald was a fag